une véritable démonstration les filles
du chesnay versailles en blanc et bleu
se sont largement imposés à domicile
contre l'union sportive la glacerie
le score est sans appel 75 à 39,7 13e
victoire de la saison en nationale 3 a
été acquise dès les premières minutes de
la rencontre avec un 13 1 après quatre
minutes de jeu passé les matches qui
sont difficiles à jouer parce que c'est
une équipe qui est bas de tableau
clairement qui joue qui joue son
maintien
donc elles ont elles ont rien à perdre à
lyon avec les crocs donc faut faire
attention pour palais faut pas les
prendre de haut au tout de suite rentré
dans le match est concentré on a réussi
à le faire donc c'est bien je pense
qu'on était sérieux on était concentré
et à la fin les cartes qu'on a fait
c'est je pense qu'on le mérite
cette victoire permet aux féminines du
chesnay versailles de conserver la
première place du championnat
le fcv 78 compte trois points d'avancé
sur le duo gravenchonnais angers après
14 journées
des résultats qui permettent d'envisager
une montée en fin de saison
moi j'aime pas trop parler de ça je
préfère prendre comme toutes les filles
d'ailleurs match après match
une seconde saison c'est longuet encore
les play-offs après voilà on sait que ce
n'est pas parce qu'on termine 1re de la
poule comptent donc voilà on y va match
après match et on verra s'il ya monté à
prendre part à monter on prendra
prochain match pour les féminines du
chesnay versailles le dimanche 10
février sur le terrain de chartres une
équipe classée dernière du championnat
un match à la portée des joueuses de
vinko var dietsch qui permettra sans
doute de préparer la rencontre décisive
contre angers à la fin du mois
[Applaudissements]